بشيء من علمه الا بما شاء وسيح الكرسي
والسماوات
لا يقول
من النار الله ما جنا من النار الله ما جن
من النار الله ما جهن من النار الله ما
جنا من النار الله ما ج من الله ما من
اللهمك
[Arabic recitation]
العالمين والصلاه والسلام على رسوله
الكريم وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان
لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده
ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعده
الصالحين
ابي هريره عبد الرحمن بن صخر رضي الله عنه
هذا الصحابي الجليل هو من اعلام
الصحابه وهو حافظهم ومحدثهم
وهو من فقهاء الصحابه ومن قراء الصحابه
فان روايه
نافع عن طريق ابي هريره رضي الله عنه وقد
اخذ القران عن النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
وضبطه على ابي بن كعب رضي الله عنه
فاسانيد نافع
اييه اسانيد نافع رحمه الله تعالى
وطلابه
قالون
وورش
عن طريق ابي هريره رضي الله عنه كثير من
الناس يغفل عن هذه
فكثير ممن اراد
ان يطعن في سنه رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم وان يطعن في الحديث النبوي الشريف من
اجل ان يتلعب في القران كما يشاء هذا هو
السبب لماذا
يطعن الطاعن في حديث رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم لانه يريد
لزيغ في قلبه ان يتلعب في معاني ايات كتاب
الله فان الشيطان نظر الى هذا الكتاب
العظيم الذي انزله الله سبحانه وتعالى
واي عيسى ان يحرفه
لفظا
كما فعل في الكتب السابقه
ثم طمع ا في تحريف
فهم
المسلمين
طمع في تحريف فهم الناس لكتاب الله
وهذا الفهم
اعني الفهم المنحرف الذي هو مبناه على ا
الهوى
يقول الله تعالى
فيه ايات محكمات هن ام الكتاب واخر
متشابهات
فاما الذين في قلوبهم زيغ فيتبعون ما
تشابه منه ابتغاء الفتنه
ابتغاء الفتنه و الفتنه وابتغاء تاويله
ايش تاويله يعني تاويل نفسه التاويل الذي
هو يريد يريد التاويل الذي يحلو له ويهواه
فيقف سدا مانعا بينه وبين هذا المرام حديث
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
ف
عمد اقوام الى الطعن في حديث رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم وكيف يفعلون ذلك
بالطعن في الرواه
ومن ابرز او هو ابرز رواه الصحابه ابو
هريره عبد الرحمن بن صخر الدوسي الازدي
رضي الله عنه فينبغي علينا ان ا ننظر في
سيرته
وان ننظر في حديث رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم
لكي
نكون على يقين مما يرويه لنا هذا الصحابي
الجليل ابو هريره رضي الله عنه قد دعا له
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم في الحديث
المشهور ابسط رداءك فبسط رداءه فدع الله
سبحانه وتعالى له الا ينسى فقال ابو هريره
رضي الله عنه فما نسيت حديثا بعده قط.
اسلم ابو هريره رضي الله عنه
في عام خيبر واختلف المؤرخون
في سنه اسلامه او في عفوا اختلف المؤرخون
في شهوده
خيبر هل كان مع المقاتلين في خيبر ام قادم
على رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم بعد
انتهاء
المعركه والذي عليه كثير من المؤرخين
والمحدثين
هو ان ابا هريره رضي الله عنه قدم وقت
القتال وضرب له سهم في المغانم وكان ابو
هريره رضي الله عنه من اهل الصفه
ما هي الصفه
سنشرح ان شاء الله ابو هريره
‏more
translate
here
are important because
a
pillar
صلى الله عليه وسلم 2000
رضي الله عنه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
make up
م صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏inicology
ofid
and so
individ wished to change the qu if they
could they would change words if they
could they would and call themselves
they would just the prev nation
‏unable to
keep their books in theirs
and that of the b which is
a
however the key method of the
preservation of the quر is through the
institutional
of the schar
‏comm
unableر
not
letter imposs
and so the next method is to change the
understanding
of what has been said by
ر
الشيطان those desire
things have agendas
they havee
they have certain ideas that they wish
to push on to the qu
the ques
and specifices
‏in this isund
and all
however
it is not clear and perfect to those who
wish it to what it does not
be ‏by the prev nation
murderers
and
criminals and terrible people they used
the
injil
they used
asidence to support their crimes and
likewi there are people who use the
verses of the quر in the way that they
wish
[Silence]
ى الله عليه وسلم
حديث صلى الله عليه
بخاري
مسلم رحمهم الله تعالى
بخاري مسلم
حديث ابو هريره رضي الله
حديث are
people andar
with
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم حديث
that
the of the propet
is some happen stance maybe wishful
thinking some musls
حث
حديث kind
of books of the bible
add to the b later
and
what a compon
and indeed
حديث prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
حديث
احمد
صلى الله عليه وسلم
how can be sure are actually props and
are things people and as if the
was some kind of
primitive nation that by idly as people
wrte en books
‏compعين
asم
mighty nation of is some cast nation has
noy
‏haveousy over to
addes
of into prophسمut
notigion
andر and have been transm to us by best
of
and bl with in and
صلى الله عليه وسلم
in
order to preserve
every letter every movement every
gesture
صلى الله عليه وسلم
andn
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه
‏up and the
is impossibility
just cann day and at the same time
it cann be black and white at the time
just the quرal
and preserved letter and
ممد صلى الله عليه وسلم.
[Silence]
‏But there are those who wearancy hats
and have in their pockets and wear ni
glasses and have lots of derees and to
be schar and to be all kinds of things
and have millions of followers on
Instagram and have this and that and
they bring up
things that they
areid
arguments against the validity حديث are
into
mother resources and intoation
of prop and
theران
can never underst proper without
صلى الله عليه
اللهر
[Silence]
عليه
‏are
so aware
never
to
the village idiot every vage one
unfortun there are villages of idiots
now and so we have to prepare ourselves
and not be so ignorant of our ownigion
that every time someone says
والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
العالمين وجزاكم الله خيرا
جزاكم